[موسيقى]
ض
جيج اي خمسه ايام مضت لكنه تسلل من ليله
هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا بين الجنانين هدوء
ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله مخططات جاهزه
للتحشيد واطلاق الرصاصه الاولى طرفات صراع
قطع وعودا وقدمات تنازلات بحضور وسطاء
بهدف نزع فتيل للتنافس بينهما وفق صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز وفيما كانت الالات العسكريه
المتنافسه تستعد للقتال تدفقت القوات
بهدوء على معسكرات الجيش المتنافسه في
جميع انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم بدايه الخلاف
وبحسب الصحيفه خرجت من قلق حمد المتمثل
باختراق الجيش من قبل موالينا للنظام
السابق فيما بدات المخابرات العسكريه
بقياده البرهان في اخبار المسؤولين
الاجانب بان حمد حاول سرا استيراد طائرات
مسلحه من دون طيار من تركيا لتعزيز قوته
فالخلافات لوحدت حتى بين افراد الجيش
والدعم السريع الذين تعاملك قوتين
متنافستين وليس منسجمتين ضمن نفس الدوله
لكن ما ادى الى تفاقم الخلاف اكثر محاوله
الاتفاق على دمج القوتين في جيش واحد
خصوصا ان هذه العمليه ستخرج حمدتي الخاسره
الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوثه الامريكي
حين سقطت الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق
السودان الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره
وامال الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان
فجر كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب
ضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات